bill maher who is a liberal but he's a
liberal in a little more of an
old-school way
he is furious about this and he said
that nothing
nothing is ever good enough for the
democrats if lin-manuel miranda is going
to be thrown out
then there's simply no pleasing these
people there's latinx performers
one black lead but no afro latinx
the committee that makes note of
everyone's skin tone
discovered this and then lynn miranda
had to
say i'm truly sorry i'm learning from
the feedback i thank you for raising it
and i'm listening
i promise to do better in my future
projects
this is what i was talking about with
nikki please stop the apologizing you're
the guy who made the founding fathers
black and hispanic
i don't think you have to apologize to
twitter
for sake
[Applause]
this is why people hate democrats it's
cringy
no look he's wrong he's right that it's
cringy he's right that this is insane
he's right that it's so
ridiculous but he's wrong that this is
why people hate democrats
this is why democrats are successful
because they
never give an inch they never go off
script
they never accept republican premises
they never accept the premises of
reality
i'm not just talking republican premises
you know like babies or babies
okay it seems like that's just a premise
of reality but let's go
even further let's go even more to what
we just see with our own eyes
the left will not accept the plain fact
that men are not women
the most controversial line that's ever
gotten me in trouble i've gotten in
trouble for a few lines
most of which in my view have been true
but the one that's really gotten me in
trouble is the idea that men are not
women
and the left insists on this they stick
to their guns
when they're pushing their radical
ideology nobody is safe it's not like
well
hey that's fair we'll meet in the middle
you've gone far enough you know that's
kind of the republican attitude
the democratic attitude is no uh-uh oh
you made a whole musical only about
racial minorities only in this minority
neighborhood
and the whole cast is non-white yeah
they're still too white
yeah all that there's no white people
yeah well the non-white people are still
too white
darker go darker lin cry grovel
beg shine my shoes lin
that's the way that they think and
one cannot deny that that strategy
has been successful maybe just
maybe conservatives could learn from
this
we make fun of it we should but we
should we should laugh about it but not
in the just dismissive way that bill
maher is laughing about we need to take
it seriously
because the fact is it's been successful
and we should try to be successful too
hey stop right there i'm glad you liked
the video there's a whole episode go
watch it right now you can watch it on
youtube it's called controlling
words controlling minds you can also
listen at apple podcast google play
spotify stitcher
you can subscribe there leave the
five-star review ring the bell subscribe
here and speaking of controlling words
controlling minds you can order not
pre-order but order my book
was just released today speechless
controlling words controlling lines go
order it see you next time